you know you're going up in the world
when the CEO of Apple speaks at your
annual work get-together it is an honor
to be here with you today and he's
joined by Sir Tim berners-lee this will
be a good idea and Mark Zuckerberg I'm
sorry I can't be with you in person and
did I mention Google sundar pichai we
look forward to continuing to engage on
these important topics all lined up to
woo this Brussels summit where
representatives from across the
continent worked out technological
solutions to the kind of cross-border
conundrums that could barely have been
conceived of as far back as 2016 what no
not that kind of summit something far
more important real power for those who
know where to see it in that room are
the world's data protection
commissioners and honestly if you saw
them on the street you wouldn't think
twice but there's more raw regulated
power in that one room then maybe in the
whole of Whitehall and Westminster put
together and that's because of GDP our
are only six months old already the
cause of a lot of frustration and
confusion but it empowers these people
to take on big tech it's because of GDP
are that the crucial player of this
summit is once again Ireland whose
Commissioner rules over all the US tech
firms based in Dublin so it feels like a
huge responsibility it also feels like a
privilege that we get to look at these
issues of how big tech in particular is
interfacing with users and we're really
pleased now that we have a new legal
framework in Europe it gives us a very
strong and broad toolkit as an enforcer
but also a supervisor but even here
brexit casts a long shadow at a press
conference of the key players Tim
berners-lee couldn't hide his dismay the
UK government emitted their hand even
started preparations for a day to deal
on brexit are you personally worried and
can you give us some sense of what it
would mean if data actually stopped
flowing between the UK and the EU ago
she Asians must admit to being
personally very disappointed
Rex and the UK's data Commissioner
emphasized the need for a solution all
of us are hoping that cooler heads will
prevail and there will be a data deal
that allows us at least a transitional
period where the UK could apply for
adequacy and data would continue to flow
during a transition period I think
that's really important
No Deal no easy movement of data from
tech billionaires to the UK's online
shoppers a lot rests on the decisions of
the most powerful people you never knew
existed Rollem on top
Sky News